for a second night in a row the nba
playoffs will be shut down
as athletes across the sports world
stand in solidarity
against racial injustice but here's the
big question
will this movement now spread to the
worlds of
tv movies and music
it's just it's very troubling it's very
troubling and you know my prayers go to
that family
i think the most difficult part is to
see like
people still don't care it's amazing
why we keep loving this country and this
country
does not love us back most of us come
from these same neighborhoods that
people are getting gunned down and
killed
i think the nba needs to wake up the
wave of protests began with the
milwaukee bucks decision to boycott
their playoff game
following the police shooting of jacob
blake in the team's home state
despite the overwhelming plea for change
there has been no action
it wasn't something that they planned to
do kev perhaps it was a rash decision
but it was a historical decision and
this
powerful tv moment as a black man as a
former player
i think it's best for me to support the
players
and just not be here tonight kenny smith
one of the hosts of inside the nba
walked off the set last night to show
solidarity moments later
former nba star chris webber addressed
the tv audience
very proud of the players and they have
everybody's attention around the world
right now
athletes across professional sports
halted games including the wnba
the washington mystics wore white
t-shirts spelling out jacob blake's name
their backs painted with seven bullet
holes
this morning another twist nba players
agreed to resume the postseason
there is also something that people
aren't thinking about and that's the
financial
issues involved there's a lot of young
players and i remember my first four or
five years in the nba
kevin at the end of every summer i was
broke i needed those checks
some of these guys i'm sure are in
similar situations and this is their
livelihood i understand why some people
still want to play i don't know if
everybody will ever be on the same page
and hollywood is joining in taking a
stand this morning press interviews for
tenet were postponed
in solidarity with those experiencing
social injustices
you